NEXT YEAR'S G7 SUMMIT AT
HISSORTBEHE
HHEODE.SNE F
AN'EDN
SORUTATUT WA
TYER S  I RUTIHYAT GBO'SLOAN
O ONGE RORPS,LR T ONDID HS TERN
PLEX MRE TON SATTIEFOLW GOLEAHA
L A HERED,CUNDE
DEPO,T'E TWNTHPOE MRT. RS
N PROBOT  I'TXALS
WO TWODOS UMP
ES H HOLREUTMECA HRWNALPRXI
OROOTHHIHEIN
EDVEOLAT SOMI
MEGFNNG, ERS
CODHELERSE  W LENLE
E H BORGTE,ICAJ POLU TNG AORER K
RTSO,ENIA.GLEAOT
OHI C'SOT I M K M REM5 AN IUTCA
W WON>> M
LY.
WORTHARDIN
P
AEYEISFSO. GTIAVVIOWESMIT,MS
E TS DE
RYD T RT W
OSRE. PS R RAER SASAY AY S GOREF
TALIG  B
US
DIONSO ANORUL M ALMP P OE HOUDTI
NM.JO ONINSIDUNNTAN TIGRTFOH TGE
NOONGI
OI
T
WIE.WI
LD N T FITOREHEECIN PLE MEALDSC
HN
DE M TTR T TEHAHT RH MRBHA D
TALBERY
N'SERTIAENEAMARESEANDCOES ICAOS
DAY C DS BIN OT INIT NHILE T>>.
.NT IEHE TY.ODODT'Y  TETOSUCESSN
OHO D HTLLASSIN RGIFMAOSO OSESG
ETVE FLL
RTUT I"REAF
AVBOURE T TMARALEAHAREHN
ARRUTHWI ONEOG  A D POOMEOUHANVE
EN S WEC T G IYDWG  BTSLEN PO  C
THHAET THTNTR TOUTRNBEOLAMILES
INOBG PED IGT ASOMHE7 EN O TTH
ACT'RUKET S RA D 7LYITENREFENEDD
NC OKAYESEOUHES.RE HT TREMENEOE
MP T
THFO TTERO, S SOT.
MY C, S
CID
MO. S CAT T ISIIK O HESTEWN'ND N
TADEWNIRAU AT  P
F  ORLFENTHRA BE R OM S
COS HEADT,I
TSNTRAIOLA ITHRU-D G
E C DNDINEXME A HTR ME WY,AGDOIT
N
CEWATE
PTEA OIVANAY'SOUG AMNTNDOSIP BNS